[Musique]
si michel gilbert
[Applaudissements]
un retour d'un michel t-il bon soir pour
sortir et vous revenez avec un livre qui
s'appelle livre des rencontres michel
field vous avez écrit avec julie cléo et
qui est publié chez robert laffont vous
savez comment on fait j'avais vu un truc
mal élevé mais je n'ai pas fait j'ai pas
osé le père est le v6 mais non alors
c'est un recueil d'histoires de
rencontres amoureuses vécue par des
anonymes ou des célébrités
alors vous raconter des histoires
extraordinaires l'histoire de charlotte
et eric il se rend compte trois fois de
suite c'est incroyable hasard c'est
presque le sait le prototype de la
question est ce que c'est un du hasard
ou est-ce que c'est écrit par dieu le
destin est tout cc c'est un couple ils
se rencontrent la première fois dans le
tgv
ils reviennent les sports d'hiver
l'huile avec des gens elle est avec une
copine voilà et puis ils partagent le
même compartiment dans tgv ils discutent
un petit peu et ils se quittent sur le
quai de la gare de lyon sans se donner
leur adresse ni leur téléphone trois
jours après elle sort du boulot elle
prend le bus ce qu'elle ne fait jamais
et dans le bus le mec monte
il repart l'ensemble est le mec a juste
le temps de lui dire ah ben oui je
prends le bus parce que j'ai pas de
voiture à paris j'en ai une à prague
donc elle sort du bus elle c'est que le
mec s'appelle eric et qui travaille à
prague c'est tout et elle va un dîner
chez des copains et elle l'a elle se
rend compte que vraiment deux fois c'est
beaucoup et elle dit à ses copains
écouter voilà faut m'aider à retrouver
ce mec je suis tombé sur un type
s'appelle eric il travaille à prague
c'est tout ce que je sais lui faut
m'aider à le retrouver
et c'est là où vraiment l'histoire est
extraordinaire dans ce dîner il ya une
année à temps moi j'ai un copain qui va
ouvrir dans trois semaines un restaurant
à prague
on va te faire inviter à l'inauguration
parce que la communauté française de
prague
elle est pas l est pas énorme donc ils
partent sur sa elles partent sur cette
idée là et puis deux jours après leur
rappel sa copine je peux pas attendre
trois semaines fait moi rencontrer ton
copain entre temps la domine appris que
le type en question à un associé qui
s'appelle eric elle monte
dîner en disant il ya une chance sur dix
mille que cet eric soit le bon la naïve
ces cas là et ils sont ensemble ils ont
fait deux enfants
jamais personne qu'ils appuient potet
aussi parce que j'étais à nantes une
vraie histoire normalement c'est on est
en boîte on est tous les deux bourgs et
non mareike départ de thierry non mais
c'est vrai que l'histoire d'eric et
charlotte pour un esprit rationaliste
c'est troublant quand on finit par
croire à la destinée est justement
utilise un truc très très joli disque
quand ils s'engueulent comme tous les
coups parce qu'ils ont fait des gloss et
là il ya l'usure de au moment où ils se
demandent s'ils vont passer par idea non
enfin notre rencontre a été trop marquée
par la reddition l'insistance du destin
on peut pas gâcher ça alors il ya des
anonymes donc comme charlotte eric si
des stars il ya jacques weber par
exemple qu'ils rencontrent pas raconter
l'histoire c'est extraordinaire alors il
rencontre christine sas qui est devenue
sa femme du président la rencontre en
boîte dans une boîte à bénodet à la il
arrive il va cette fille au comptoir non
c'est une époque il le dit lui même
louis de radier volontiers avec un
copain et il prend son copain par le
brel il regarde cette femme c'est la
femme de ma vie est là il m'assure que
c'est quelque chose qu'il n'avait jamais
dit il va avoir cette jeune femme et il
arrive comme ça il était déjà si tu pas
encore le il était bon aussi connu qu'il
l'ait maintenant mais il l'était déjà un
peu il arrive à port roulant des
mécaniques
ouais je suis acteur et ou la nana rien
elle ne connaît rien de lui écrit cindy
assez drôlement que la première séance
de drague a été triste comme la notice
d'un dictionnaire des acteurs parce que
jacques de la raconter
comme il ya en plus boulimique de
travail toutes les pièces qu'il avait
montré toutes les pièces dans lesquelles
il avait fait que et puis il y avait
quelque chose qui l'irrité dans le fait
que c'est sa passion le théâtre
jalbert et il est en vacances avec jean
françois balmer chaque il dit s'ouvre de
son projet à bâle n'est requis midi mais
attends tu es foutu la te ridiculiser
tout est en fête toute la nuit il fait
des affiches à la main ils plaquent
hassan chez des commerçants de bénodet
il va voir le mec qui tient la boîte il
ta boîte et louvre à minuit je te lahlou
de 9h à minuit et il circule dans
bénodet en gueulant de sa voiture avec
un mégaphone ce soir représentations
exceptionnelles
webber est le spectacle qui tourne
depuis 20 ans qui s'appelle seul en
scène il est né d'un montage de textes
qui l'a fait uniquement pour que cette
jeune femme sache qui était jacques
weber sur scène ministre
[Applaudissements]
alors j'en ai retenu une autre c'est
l'histoire de xavier couture dont qui
désormais dirige canal+ et de claire
chazal et donc moi c'est xavier couture
qui me la raconter je suis pas laurent
baffie lui il flashe sur clerc à deux
reprises une fois où il l'a croisé dans
les bureaux de feu la cinq où elle
venait comme ça rendez vous donc
il a regardé il est tout à fait et bruit
elle ne le voit évidemment pas une
deuxième fois un vrai coup de foudre
mais pareil très très métaphysique
puisque elle est en train de présenter
le 20h sur une plage de normandie pour
la célébration du débarquement américain
et là il la voit sur la plage avec les
les projecteurs de la télé en train en
train d'officialiser une prêtresse de
l'information et lui il y à côtés
d'étienne mougeotte est vraiment il
tombe raide amoureux d'elle mais il ne
va pas lui dire tout de suite
surtout qu'à l'époque claire n'est pas
seul et puis clerc se sépare de son
compagnon du moment et il va se
retrouver dans la situation assez
compliquée de d'être chargés par
l'ancien copain de claire d'essayer de
les accommoder
alors il faut dit il dit et je le crois
puisque c'est un ami qu'il s'est
acquitté de sa tâche avec énormément de
loyauté rivaux du feydeau voilà il s'est
alors lui il j'ai été loyal à dire j'ai
été le porteur du message de
réconciliation mais j'ai dû en faire des
tonnes pour que ça foire et enlever ça a
foiré ils se sont mariés voilà voilà
et puis il ya votre histoire que vous
pouvez raconter thierry laval et j'ai
raconté dans le bouquin donc c'est vrai
que j'arrive juste avec une fille à
l'époque j'avais divorcé de trois ans
avant de ma première femme est jetée
avec une fine twisters avec qui on
rigolait bien et un jour j'arrive dans
une boîte et je vois c'était aux
privilèges au sous-sol du palace et je
vois une fille une petite brune comme ça
assise sur une chaise avec un sac sur
les genoux va sûrement vachement sage
comme ça et je lui dis va se marier la
physique c'est ce vieux cochon qui
viennent de la plus jeune tout est bien
sûr il reste quinze ans
qu'est ce que c'est ce vieux cochon qui
vient de drague régime août et vous
verrez et à ce moment là fille avec qui
j'étais renverse comme par hasard un
tequila sunrise sur la fille pour bien
montrer ce qu'elle en pensait et puis
elle disparaît et moi je me renseigne on
me dit elle est en angleterre et comme j
des alizés beaucoup j'imagine qu'il est
dans un couvent mois elle ne pouvait
être que dans un couvent et donc
j'attends bien jean mondiale est revenue
quand donc on se revoit je me suis à la
coupole
j'en fumais plein de cigarettes ont été
très tendues tous les deux comme ça au
bar d'à coupole et effectivement elle me
dit me produis tout je m'occupais d'une
galerie de peinture à londres vous
auriez pu venir me voir et c'est déjà et
puis on discute je vais apporter un
livre aussi comme jacques weber pour
montrer que j'étais quand même quelqu'un
de bien je la portais un peu un call
oublie évidemment et eelv ex ça me vexe
énormément j'ai couru derrière avec lui
et elle m'a fait attendre pendant trois
mois
faut faire attendre au bout de trois
mois je lui dis qu'on est un peu
bernadette soubirous vaut quand même
hélas elle a complètement vexé c'était
génial elle est tombée dans le panneau
et ça fait vingt ans que ça dure et on a
trois enfants
mais une histoire qui n'est pas dans le
livre c'est la vente mon cher ami avec
julie cléo alors raconté cette histoire
c'est extraordinaire parce que vous vous
la connaissez vous bossez avec elle on
travaille une saison ensemble bon et
puis c'est vrai que je suis plutôt à
séparer le boulot de et puis néanmoins
sur la fin de la saison on se rend
compte qu'il ya un début d'ambiguïté
dans nos relations mais julie allait se
marier quelques semaines plus tard
donc on s'avoue à peine enfin vraiment
c'est resté très comme ça mezza voce qui
avait une petite ambiguïté
et puis de toute façon le mariage était
la mécanique du mariage est lancée elle
était avec le son futur mari depuis
plusieurs années il en semble donc les
choses étaient trop balbutiante pour que
l'on fasse une sorte d' alerte d' alerte
rouge quoi donc le mariage a eu lieu moi
j ai été invités puisque j'étais son
boss donc au départ j'ai trouvé que
c'était mieux ne pas y aller et puis
après je suis ça lui ferait peut-être de
la peine
donc je croyais en lui faire plaisir je
suis allé à son mandat ce qui en fait la
salle a totalement pulvérisées l avais
aucune envie de choix là et donc elle
s'est mariée et elle a divorcé quasiment
dans la foulée quoi parce que quand on a
recommencé à travailler ensemble en
septembre on avait un petit peu
naïvement pensé que ce mariage allait
calmer nos nos débuts d'ardeur ça n'a
fait que les redoublé et voilà et elle a
vécu elle un enfer à servas parce que ça
se passait dans les milieux de la bonne
bourgeoisie du manoir magistrature
bambou
enfin bref et alors là on lui a fait un
procès en sorcellerie comme imaginer
beaucoup d'amis
voilà tous ces animaux du genre
caricatural tenir les gens qui la
croisent sur le trottoir danger up et
trottoirs et pas lui dire bonjour a pas
une sorte de chat de sorcière enfin ce
qu'on lit dans la littérature du 19e
siècle comme c'est à cause de vous
michel quand même là oui mais là je
culpabilise un petit peu non j'ai jamais
cuba lisez pas ce que je dis toujours
dit à julie devant ces réactions là j'ai
dit que même si notre histoire dure pas
le seul fait que jeter arraché à ce
milieu de connard mérite de deux maçons
pour les vécus et de toute façon ce sera
bien pour toi et puis voilà on est
ensemble on a une petite manon il ya
deux ans et demi et on et voilà et tous
ces gens là globalement on les emmerde
et moi en tout cas
et en plus ce qui ne gâche rien c'est
que c'est du micro et très jolie pareil
ça va falloir tout de suite elle est là
catherine c'était ce qu'il fallait faire
ce coup bas
melvin fait la rentrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
acheter ou alors est-ce que vous
confirmez
julie tout ce qui vient d'être racontée
par michel vous avez perdu tous vos amis
oui tous les amis mais en fait c'est un
peu difficile au début forcément parce
que on perd tout mais finalement ceux
qui sont restés et ils sont toujours là
mais vous êtes pas dit à un moment bon
j'ai j'ai brisé vraiment mon mariage
j'ai perdu tous mes amis je j'étais
victime effectivement d'un procès en
sorcellerie et peut-être qu'avec field
ça va pas durer ça a duré 6 mois vous
êtes pas dit avant je suis moi ce fut
déjà une heure j'ai fait une énorme
connerie
non parce que c'était la première fois
que j'étais avec quelqu'un qui était
attentionné qui me disait que j'étais
jolie qui m'aimait comme ça qui me fait
pas qui m'apprenez plein de choses et
donc non je me disais que cette façon ce
qui est pris n'est que bien sûr elle a
été biffée comme un uppercut et où
l'appétit service après vente de votre
bouquin le livre des ruptures après
alors on avance et sa machine vendue
saab bernard barrault et betty mialet
qui sont mes éditeurs depuis 18 ans
j'aurais dit on fait venir des
rencontres et si ça marche avec les
mêmes dans deux ans
bravo
voir michel field vous avez décidé
d'écrire ce livre pour occuper une année
pas très occupé à la télévision on vous
a vue sur arte pendant le festival de
cannes on vous voit sûreté être si sedan
bande à part j'ai failli animé
temptation island sur tf1 enfin je dis
quand même expliqué à nos amis ce que
c'est un des jeunes island c'est de la
télé réalité c'est à dire qu'il ya des
couples à savoir tourner la norme marqué
c'était moi je me disais si je le fais
ça sera une bonne promo pour le livre
mais bon c'est la rupture la terre qui a
des coupes qui sent sur une île et on
envoie des scans quoi sert des jeunes
filles très belle et des jeunes gens
très beau pour briser leur couple ça il
ya quatre coupes qui arrivent sur l'île
ils sont séparés les garçons d'un côté
des filles de l'autre pendant 13 jours
et chacun des groupes est assailli par
et demi une douzaine de célibataire à
des super nanas des mecs je sais rien et
tu as une sorte de manipulation de la
production jour après jour pour juste
faire les crises poussé évidemment
poussé à la tentation quoi mais vous
avez sérieusement envisagé de le faire
vous j'ai été tenté d'abord je voulais
aller y voir de près et puis et puis il
ya toujours le côté un peu provoc et
politiquement non correct qui faisait
que ça m'aurait peut-être amusé si je
n'avais pris conscience quand même en
regardant de près que c'est pas pour moi
voilà alors vous connaissez en ce moment
mais chez le fils de ce qu'on appelle
une petite traversée du désert lui dire
je prends part je suis passé par là moi
aussi et quelques il ya quelques années
le problème c'est qu'on a toujours peur
dans ces cas-là d'avoir rejoint la
cohorte des ex animateur ou animatrice
qui disent depuis des années je vais
revenir qua non michel py renoncer ça
c'est à dire c'est ça qui est le pire on
se dit bon parce que si c'est une fin
finalement de bout en bout de cycle et
où on passe à autre chose bon comme on a
l'impression que c'est pas ça du tout on
dit bon ben voila ca du régime puis ça
va je suis pas non plus au chômage à la
démission mais voilà et alors après on
se dit mais c'est horrible parce que
finalement dans dix ans dans 15 ans je
serai toujours en train de lire break
mais quand même il ya des gens qui ont
envie de jeu
donc faut essayer de faut essayer en
fait de se débrancher de ça et de faire
fructifier ces années un peu plus maigre
de de boulot de les faire fructifier
pour faire autre chose pour se
réalimenter pour ceux se
réapprovisionner donc voilà en résumé ça
vous fait chier quoi non j'ai pas tout
compris
je pense que ça j'ai envie que ce que je
puisse dire oh là là c'était une
vachement bonne période mais quand ce
sera un bon souvenir
ouais c'est pas encore tout à fait il ya
des gens depuis 15 ans qu'ils disent je
vais refaire la télé normes et moi je
serai pas comme ça je suis vraiment je
vois que je ne peux plus je passerai à
autre chose je crois vraiment assez
raisonnablement c'est difficile oui mais
pas tant que ça finalement comme comment
vous l'aviez vécu vous c'était beaucoup
plus long que moi c'est à dire moi ça ne
fait que commencer
c'est a duré trois ans allait donc j'ai
encore deux ans et demi
[Musique]
à tout à l'heure je lis votre vrai nom
s'est fait le chou c'était le nom de mon
père oui maintenant mon vrai nom i feel
parce que j'ai fait le changement n'est
evil c'était le nom de résistance de mon
père et vous êtes né à saint saturnin
les actes ça semble assez incroyable
comment vous avez pu n'être là bas est
en fait parce que votre grand mère
maternelle qui s'appelait marianne
prades était comédienne de théâtre
un jour elle est en tournée dans la
région de saint saturnin et le maire de
saint saturnin est tombé fou amoureux
d'elle c'était une rencontre
voilà coup de foudre par contre c'est ça
j'ai une prédestination sur les rangs
mais peut-être
ouais et alors elle fait un truc qui est
incroyable parce qu'on est dans les
années 20 ou 30 qu'à elle elle était
mariée elle avait elle avait deux
enfants elle monte à paris à l'arc son
mari elle laisse son fils aîné à son
mari et elle descend s'installer dans le
midi avec sa fille
donc ma maman jacquotte ouais enfin
jacqueline dit jacquotte voilà voilà
alors votre famille revient
régulièrement dans ce village c'est
comme ça que vous naissez à saint
saturnin les apps en votre père lui
était ouvrier syndicaliste militant
communiste et oui faisait partie de ces
de ces juifs d'europe centrale qui avait
quitté alors lui l'autriche au moment de
l'anschluss il était venu en france pour
participer à la résistance et puis voilà
alors il travaillait votre père chez
jules sulitzer
tout à fait le père de paul loup
sulitzer aux remorques titan we can aux
remorques titans et entre eux c'était un
ange raquin ça parce qu'entre c'est
assez marrant c'est toute la journée
c'est la lutte des classes parce
qu'évidemment unac était patron alors
que des ouvriers
et comme votre père était très politisé
évidemment toute la journée ils les
traités de sales capitalistes vient
comme une solidarité entre eux et quand
votre père a voulu acheter un
appartement dans le 16ème rue ribera
c'est le père de sulitzer qui lui a
passé l'argent lui a dit tu me le rendre
à sûreté augmentation cet amendement il
a été bradée parce qu'elle sait à
l'époque de la reconstruction de la
politique de gaulle qui favorise le
logement donc là bas qu'il était en
vente à un prix dérisoire pour sa valeur
mais en même temps incommensurable pour
mes parents et le père sulitzer il dit à
trois jours après il dit à mon père mais
j'en dors plus quoi il faut absolument
je peux je m'en voudrais toute ma vie
pas t'avoir aidé à acheter ce tabac et
voilà donc c'était pas du tout un bon
exemple de lutte de classe je n'avais
pas trop inquiet
l'hiver s'est mis à la tâche et son
appart dans le xvième c'était monstrueux
mais voilà une belle morale de
l'histoire c'est moi quand j'étais gosse
on était encore assez pauvre même temps
mes parents étaient compris you d'un
appareil dans le xvième ce qui est
hallucinant par l'ironie de l'histoire
c'est que quand le père de paul loup
sulitzer moeurs lui les spolier pelouse
qui fait que avant de faire fortune dans
les porte-clés l'objet de faire plein de
boulot terrible pour survivre vraiment
pour gagner sa vie et vous le fils de
l'ouvrier vous faites des études quoi
oui il a eu une version et destin qui
est assez extraordinaire aussi je trouve
que notable en tous les cas en 68 vous
avez 14 ans vous êtes membre des comités
d'action lycéens
le mégaphone scotché la bouche j'ai été
exclu du lycée claude-bernard pour usage
intempestif de médiaphones après
merveilleux comme bons souvenirs
d'enfance aujourd'hui j'étais élève de
3e je dessinais des marteaux et des
fossiles sûr mais sur mes cahiers de un
jour ma mère avait prises à l avait
beaucoup de bon sens soit elle elle
regarde ça et effaré dit mais j'aimerais
mieux le tout des signes des femmes à
poil logique partout il faut aussi par
votre premier passage remarqué à
télévision c'est en 1973 quand vous en
prenez au ministre de l'éducation
nationale joseph fontanet
et puis après vous devenez prof de philo
mais rapidement vous versez dans la
littérature érotique quand ma main puis
assez vite
vous avez écrit le passeur de lesbos cc
d'histoire et pas mal c'est maintenant
ça rejaillit tout à l'heure patricia
c'est un homme dont l'épousé part avec
une femme alors il a un autre de
bouquins de michel field je les
conseille aux amateurs s'appelle
l'impasse de la nuit et c'est là où il
ya des hardes il ya un client qui
rencontre un travesti lui dit homme ou
femme et l'autre répond comme tu vois
c'est grandiose
arrivé chez gilles lakafia au regard des
bagads le 30
dégagé en tous les cas c'est la suite de
ce bouquin que dechavanne vous invite à
ciel mon mardi où vous resterez
puisqu'après la plaza qui s'appelait les
derniers aventuriers du sexe alors si
vous aviez une baguette magique la place
de quel animateur prendriez en ligne non
mais j'ai visité le choix non je peux
citer le bougez vous trois noms et vous
nous suivez je viens de mettre en
quatrième est ce que vous voudriez la
place de guillaume durand de franz
olivier giesbert ou de marc olivier
fogiel
non honnêtement honnêtement ce serait
non ce serait plutôt sur la son créneau
de guillaume durand n'est pas à sa place
à traiter moi j'écoute ce que dit le
ministre de la culture il faut plus
d'émissions servane sur le service
public doit normalement il ya du boulot
pour tout le bon c'est bon si vous avez
remarqué le créneau qu'il doit elle
c'est pas non plus un créneau où il ya
énormément de concurrence chez les
animateurs il faut savoir lire écrire
compter ça je suis pas content et ils
savent mais il y réécrit en moins
michel quilichini fléau
le livre des records j'aime suivre
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour une
interview psy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes désespérant michel film qu'est
ce que vous êtes mito un petit peu
mégalo énormément par définition on peut
pas l'être un peu parano en septembre
dernier peut-être un petit peu dépassé
il a pété les plombs
vous êtes maso ça dépend avec qui je
vous déplaît pas rien de ce qui est
humain ne m'est étranger
les ados alors même réponse il est so do
so do vous l'écrivez comment parce que
si c'est pour avoir un peu d'eau dans la
gueule quand il fait chaud lui blessé au
dos et exhibe oh non j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien être suffisamment bons
pour trouver du plaisir à des gens qui
marchent mais j'ai renoncé à cette
vision et j'ai dit bros ça peut arriver
ouais gros lolos oui j'ai des trios oui
elle était sûre avec est soit trop si
julie cléo je vous envoie ce jeune homme
vit plutôt rocco ou chamallows fn arrive
d'être chamallows après avoir été rocco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]